why ruin it's nice to meet you nice to
meet you um I like to film a lot and I
wanted to know your German it's a world
war ii film nobody it covers a theatre
that isn't usually shown in world war ii
films that how did you find yourself
well I saw I just saw 20 years ago a
documentary which got me going and I
read pretty much I've read a lot so I
love history and I was immediately drawn
to that battle because it had so many
different aspects to it you know you can
really kind of see how complex actually
war actually is you know how Paula Paula
tix plays into it and how many people
are like involved in it and and I also I
have to say I'm like now happy that I
didn't do the movie until now because in
these days of rising nationalism it's
probably good to remind people you know
what nationalism had led to you know
that's at one point American young man
you know like lost their life of
democracy and did you have any
inspiration from the 70s movie Midway
I'm more like color on my favorite more
movie is a bridge too far because it has
the same intricacy you know where you
like to really see how a military
operations planned and then like unfolds
and you've done you know a lot of movies
with lots of action
lots of disaster if you will lots of
flying to but correct me if I'm wrong
this is the first film it has a there is
a historical element of just how the
planes operate how they move it's like
the the movie tries to be as accurate as
possible
and when you would have seen how we took
everything so serious every a like small
little detail and you know and then
don't forget I mean there's like you
know like sometimes you see war movies
where they used to roam claims that's
not in this movie and this movie
everything looks exactly like it was and
how what were some of the unique
challenges just just action-wise dwell
it was like it was it was like kind of
just because nothing exists you know you
have to create everything and and so we
had to use a lot a lot of visual effects
and but you don't want to have it feel
like it's visual effects yeah I mean
it's it's and you know when you make a
superhero movies and it doesn't look
quite real people know like superheroes
don't exist you know the planes did
exist in a certain point did you know
did you work with a lot of people that
were experts on this time oh yes oh yes
I mean I mean a whole group of 3040
people I mean it's it was like we had
like we had every department had their
specialist and called them up and and
bothered them and then understand we had
people you know like we had a specialist
for the aircraft carrier
we had a fighter pilot for the
for the aerial since we had a Japanese
military specialist for the Japanese
things I mean so compare some like
Independence Day was there a lot more
like you know
oh is this meter accurate in the plane
like did you find that a new layer but
like I have to say my production
designer team Dale I kind of did an
incredible job this was all like super
perfect I mean there's photos of it so
you just built the photo yet on me and
and you had to build everything and and
and yeah I never in that respect it's
it's I have to give them intruders